welcome back everybody as we all make
health a priority this year it's
important to remember that wellness
starts at home and there are things you
can do to minimize your chances of
symptoms
and common colds and the flu so welcome
back to nanny bubby
hey yeah nice to see you live
i know i haven't seen you since january
i can't believe it but it's
true it's been since january but we're
back and we're together
we are back we're together happy healthy
new year and happy capricorn season i
just had to throw that i was going to
say that too
aren't you is it your birthday and my
birthday coming up next week right
yes ma'am yeah what day is yours again
the 18th how about yours
right and mine is the 17th so i know oh
my gosh i love it i love it
i couldn't remember which direction so
you can't wait
for us yeah so i know that everybody is
you know in the covered mindset but the
truth is
is that you know a regular cold or flu
can hit anybody at any time and that is
still out there so what i have for you
today
is a little home remedy to help you
soothe that throat
help you you know be warm and cuddly and
help you feel better kind of a
homeopathic
recipe that helps you right from your
own kitchen so we're going to start with
turmeric
you know about turmeric is
anti-inflammatory which is
amazing right did you know that i do
we're going to put them back on their
face too right
uh do they oh i should try that it's got
good color in it so we're going to put
in about a tablespoon of turmeric
and uh can you get a good shot of all
that orange in that pot
right there yeah there you go you see
that yep and then we're going to use
um a same tablespoon of ginger now the
thing about ginger
is that the ginger and the turmeric i
use both the skins on it because that's
where the vitamins and the minerals are
so if you don't have a lot of ginger and
i don't like to work with ginger as a
general rule
i will put it in the vitamix and make
cubes
and so if you have a cube and you make
ginger cubes because i put them in my
smoothies in the morning and this kind
of idea
yeah and you put them in the vitamix
with a little water with the skin to
make ice cubes out of them
so there's a tablespoon of ginger we're
going to take
um a little boop
of cayenne pepper that's how i measure
it
for a lot of cayenne pepper that's how i
measure cayenne
and then we're going to put in this
started with three cups of filtered
water
manuka honey so rocky you ever heard of
manuka honey yes i have
so tell me what you know about it
anything i know that it's anything good
and it's healthy it's the healthiest it
is it comes from new zealand
helps sore throats it helps with wound
healing externally
helps with acne and so if you're making
something that's supposed to be great
for your throat and your health
definitely use the manuka honey calls
for
uh two tablespoons but i like it a
little bit sweeter
so we're going to put it in amazing for
that one
yeah i know do i have one for that no
yeah it's not a beauty this is not a
boop poop because this takes a long time
to get out right
so we're gonna do this and while that
bruised for just a little bit because i
knew we were gonna have to take some
time to have it brew for us
just a little bit and simmer up and have
all those flavors and all that good
nutrients for us
come together i think i go right ahead
get rid of that yeah why not let's talk
about
all of this citrus so you know this is
the citrus time of the year let me turn
this up let it
um and the first thing we're going to do
with our citrus is we're going to clean
it
great and good now if you don't grow
your own
then you can use and i've i've talked
about this on the show
for rocky is the food grade hydrogen
peroxide
you just take it you probably have a
chapman bottle filled with it as i do
you spray your citrus let it sit for a
little while and then you rinse it
and then i always say look all of the
vitamin c is contained
into the skins of this so you're going
to
peel your citrus look at this it all of
that juices is just squirting
right out onto my hand all from the skin
and this is going through the biggest
organ of your body which is your skin
your epidermis
and all of that juice from the skin the
zest
is getting on here and honestly just let
it stay there let your children peel let
your
um kids children grandchildren
we're gonna take this now we're going to
strain it well
we're going to smell your kitchen right
now oh i want you to come here inspire
me and smell it
i regret that i was not um that i was
not
in the in the studio and i can't wait
until i get back so same
same that's why we're taking these tips
in so we can all be healthy
yes exactly so i'm dripping in zested
uh juice and oils from the the
skin of the tangelo and the orange i'm
gonna drink this
wow i'm jealous oh i know
that's hot and maybe there was a little
bit too much
of the kayak but i'll tell you if i were
cuddled up
watching you know the food network with
a sore throat a runny nose
this would be amazing so i wish you all
the very best
in 2021 and let's only have normal
flu and cold absolutely thank you so
much nanny bubby that
bottoms up right thank you rocky you too
and happy birthday
thank you too all right check out andy
bubby's kitchen and garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com we
also want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring this great segment jc
that looked like
a delicious and healthy drink ginger and
turmeric and honey oh i'm gonna give me
some of that this weekend i feel like we
should just be drinking that once a day
anyway
i know right it's very healthy symptoms
yeah the healthy drink to have